M night Shyamalan finally wraps up his
superhero saga this year with the
release of glass whilst the eventual
fate of all three characters currently
has the internet an uproar there's
actually a twist I think deserves a huge
round of applause throughout this video
I'll be breaking down glasses biggest
twist
well it's also discussing the tie-ins to
both unbreakable and split there will of
course be heavy spoilers here so if you
don't want to know anything in regards
to the film or its ending and I highly
suggest that you turn off now but for
everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to unbreakable follows David Dunn
the sole survivor of a train crash as he
slowly comes to the realization that he
has incredible abilities this was
followed by a seemingly detached sequel
almost 17 years later called split which
centered on Kevin Wendel chrome chromic
was a criminal with multiple
personalities that eventually manifested
into a near unstoppable creature known
as the beast save for an end credits
scene which showcased Dunn becoming
aware of the character the two films
seemed completely disconnected until the
bail finally lifted in glass and all was
revealed
we know from split that Kevin lost his
father an early age and that he was
raised by a mother that heavily abused
him and spawned his multiple
personalities in split before Kevin
becomes the Beast we see him visiting a
train station and placing flowers there
which gives an indication that something
tragic is tied to the location
beautifully in glass it turns out that
Kevin's father actually died on the same
train that caused David Donner to
discover that he had powers what's more
is that Shamma Lamma actually confirmed
that David in fact meets Kevin in
unbreakable during one of its many
encounter scenes the scene in question
happens when David is standing at the
football stadium and bumped into a woman
and her child in the scene we hear the
screams of the child as he is physically
hit which ties into the abuse suffered
by Kevin you can also hear multiple
voices during the flash which signifies
Kevin's multiple personalities this
concludes that glass cause both the
origin story of David
and Kevin window.chrome in one fell
swoop with the train crash he created
both the emergence of super heroes and
super villains whilst as a whole I was
slightly disappointed with the film that
doesn't mean that I can't appreciate the
ingenuity of this twist and it
definitely stands as one of Shama lamb's
best so what are your thoughts on the
big reveal in glass did you see it
coming and what did you think of the
film overall comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video then
please like it and check out my
breakdown of the film's ending which
will be linked at the end of this video
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for take the time to watch
this I've been definition you've been
the best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]